the roses have faded there's the last of
us so many dramatic moments so much
attention such satisfying executions oh
did you think I was talking about the
single-player campaign nah Firefly it's
all about that competitive multiplayer
The Last of Us delivers some of the most
intense and invigorating online combat
of the past few years and now the
reclaimed territories DLC pack gives you
four new places to survive or die
horribly first up is coal mine which is
more like a coal processing facility and
not the actual holes in the earth but
tomato tomahto
this wintry scene is liable to give you
a post-traumatic flashback to playing as
Ellie in that old lumber mill so make
like that plucky protagonist and use
cover wisely there's a ton of it
littered all around the periphery of the
two large buildings so make like raptors
and hunt in packs if you're still dead
sprinting towards teammates in trouble
you're bound to get in trouble yourself
so get to flanking the new silent
specter assault rifle is available as a
mid match purchasable through one of the
new preset loadout options but to put
this quiet quick-firing monster in your
custom load outs you'll have to buy it
from the PSN store coal mine also offers
some elevated positions and though the
bridge between the buildings is a bit
exposed it's a great way to tip the
scales of ground-level firefights there
are some nice long sight lines on this
map but if you're heading inside be
ready to deal with any and all close
quarters comers nail bomb trap shorty
running away to live to fight another
day all totally viable strategies the
water tower map is much more densely
populated with small buildings and
partial barriers and big hunks of junk
just lying hither and yon you may park
yourself behind one of these obstacles
and think you've found a nice spot for
an artisan crafting party but cover is
only cover until oh god no please just
make it clean I can't become a clicker
in actuality this entire map is a
flanking frenzy with its winding
alleyway
and blind corners while there are a few
situations where long-range weapons
excel and can provide effective
suppressing fire
the majority of combat on water tower is
up close and personal
so tape some scissors to the end of that
2x4 and get to swing it the Capitol on
the other hand is fairly wide open which
makes a kind of sense given that
security in the Capitol building has
been totally lacks since this whole 20
years of pandemic thing though there's a
courtyard out front that provides decent
flanking routes most encounters take
place in the Capitol building itself the
long hallways and open atriums cater to
medium to long range combat though the
ability to duck into an alcove means
that spotting enemies might be more
effective than taking a potshot or you
could just combine the two by using the
new damage marker survival skill that
tags any enemy you damage this is one of
the eight new survival skills that like
four of the new weapons are available to
try and preset loadouts but must be
purchased separately for custom use the
final new map is Wharf which is a G dang
labyrinth of tunnels hallways ramps
nooks and crannies as with pretty much
all these maps the flanking
opportunities on Wharf are real as hell
you can get some longer range stuff
going down on the periphery and with
this little elevated perch here but most
of your time will be spent in mid to
close to uh-oh too close contact lying
in wait near major passageways and using
your listen ability can help you get the
drop on tools or just equip some
crafting focused skills and litter the
ground with nail bombs worst litterer
ever the reclaimed territories will run
you $9.99 for four maps but if you pay
$19.99 for the season pass you'll get
these four maps the four band and
territories Maps a bunch of dumb hats a
grip of new survival skills and the
incredible single-player story chapter
left behind it's a great deal and it's
only around for another week so consider
it now if you'll excuse me it's time for
more multiplayer matches as I am now
fully obsessed all over again see out
there tourists